Who can remember how many types of
najasa we have listed so far with the
author?
Seven? Okay, what are they?
One and two is
human
waste. So, human feces and urine. Three
and four
al-madhi wal-wadi.
So, al-madhi is pre-ejaculate.
And al-wadi is
that which comes out
or seeps out, if you will, or oozes out.
It's kind of almost a pus
after a person urinates. Okay, number
five.
Very good. The waste
and the entirety basically of an
animal, any animal which is not
permissible to eat.
Any animal which is otherwise haram to
eat. Tayyib, number six.
Menstrual and postpartum blood. Yes,
correct. And we understand from this
menstrual and postpartum blood
Notice the detail here.
This means that regular blood, person
cuts himself, gets some blood on him. Is
this considered to be a type of najasa
or no?
No. Menstrual
blood, postpartum blood, blood that
comes from the private parts.
This is very different than
blood that comes from a cut or what have
you.
Tayyib, the seventh, which is what we
mentioned yesterday.
Lu'ab al-kalb. So, the saliva of a
dog.
[Arabic recitation]
we said that not just the saliva of a
dog, but
everything from a dog. So, the urine,
the feces, blood.
And this also goes for another type
of animal which is in this category.
A pig.
Swine.
The correct opinion is that
al al
al-khinzir
ya'khudhu hadha al-hukm, hukm lu'ab
al-kalb. Bal huwa aghladhu
fi hukmihi min lu'ab al-kalb. Li'annahu
al-hayawan al-wahid alladhi dhakarahu
[Arabic recitation]
infiradin fi al-tahrim.
khassasa al-khinzir ma' annahu
[Arabic recitation]
and final type of najasa that the author
mentions here
is al mayta.
Al mayta, a dead animal.
A dead carcass. Now, how does this
differ from an animal which is
impermissible to eat?
Well, an animal that is impermissible to
eat,
a bear, a lion,
you know, something that.
This animal
is
you know, its waste and its blood and
its saliva is all considered to be
filthy
while it's alive or dead.
Al mayta
is an animal that is otherwise
permissible to eat, but it has not been
slaughtered properly.
An animal that is otherwise permissible
to eat, but it has not been slaughtered
properly. So, the carcass of a sheep,
the carcass of a goat or camel or a cow
that just died, it got hit by a car,
right? Whatever it is.
This has died, but it does not been
slaughtered properly.
Therefore, it is referred to in the
Quran as al mayta,
a dead animal, right? And this goes for
any animal that was slaughtered
incorrectly
or slaughtered by other than a Muslim,
Christian, or Jew.
So, we have two elements here.
One is the way that it is slaughtered.
Two is the one who does the
slaughtering.
Right?
So,
these two are mentioned in two different
verses in the Quoran.
[Silence]
All right. So, we have one verse in
Surat al-Ma'idah. It's the fourth verse.
or excuse me, it's the third verse of
Surat al-Ma'idah.
In which Allah lists
the various types of
impermissible
animals to eat which have died in an
improper way. They've been slaughtered
or killed improperly. So, he mentions
[Arabic recitation]
the dead animal
and blood and lahm al-khinzir the flesh
of swine and that which has been
slaughtered for other than Allah.
If an animal has been slaughtered for
other than Allah,
it's been slaughtered for an idol, it's
been slaughtered in a ritual, even if it
is permissible to eat, a goat, a sheep,
a cow, it is considered to be filthy.
lesson.
Right? And likewise, even if a Muslim
were to say bismillah, even if someone
were to come and slaughter and say
bismillah, but he slaughtered it for
other than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
a ritual for other than Allah, then this
meat is considered what?
This is considered a mata, dead animal.
And this is a type of shirk, shirk akbar
mukhrij min millat al-Islam.
Slaughtering for other than Allah is a
type of major shirk,
which will
take a person out of the fold of
Islam wal iyadhu billah.
A person may say, "Well, how could that
happen? Do Muslims do that? do
Muslims Could that happen that a Muslim
slaughters for other than Allah?" Yes,
absolutely. Superstitions.
Where I come from, they have a custom
that if you build a house,
right? You build a new house,
and just on the day that you finish the
house and you're going to start living
in it,
they slaughter at the door.
This slaughtering, they say bismillah.
They slaughter at the door, at the
doorway. What is this for?
For the jinn
[Arabic recitation]
So that the jinn will leave them alone.
Or so that it will repel evil eye. Or so
that the shayatin will leave them alone.
They slaughter and they say bismillah,
Muslims.
Right? And then they put the knife down,
they go make salat al-asr. This is major
shirk.
Very serious, major shirk.
It's a type of ignorance that we have.
Right?
a person is having some
problems in his home. He feels like
there are some jinn or shayatin or some
magic that is done.
They pick up the phone, they call
overseas.
Well, we know, you know, my
his mom's, aunts, cousins, sister knows
this guy
that is a
a wali
right overseas.
He's a wali. They They usually go to his
grave and they
you know, go to the grave and make
dua there and do all kinds of things,
but if you slaughter
you know, say bismillah, but you
slaughter with the intention for that
this is for this wali
right? Overseas to
to protect us or ward off these demons.
So, they tell you, "Yeah, take take a
a sheep and it has to be this weight and
this size and it has to look this
and look that." And then they
slaughter it at their house.
Right? This is a type of major shirk.
This happens all the time.
All the time. This is common commonplace
in many places. Why? In Muslim
countries, Muslim lands.
Why does this happen? Ignorance.
Ibn al-Qayyim says, "Wal jahlu da'un
qatilun."
He says that ignorance is a deadly
disease.
Deadly.
And then people do things and then they
say, "Well, I didn't know." You didn't
know that it is haram to worship other
than Allah?
That's what slaughtering is, is it not?
Akhrajal Bukhari Akhrajal Imam Muslim fi
sahihi min hadithi Ali ibn Abi Talib
[Arabic recitation]
Allah."
said Allah's curse is upon the one who
slaughters for other than Allah.
And they have other slaughtering
rituals, Muslims. Right? So, for
instance,
one of the rituals
in many Muslim countries where tribes
are a big thing,
if they hear that a tribe leader is
coming to visit or a president or what
have you,
they will line up the sheep or the
camels or the cows,
and as he arrives to the village and
comes in, they will all slaughter
as he enters and the blood is there at
his feet.
And then they leave these carcasses.
This is a type of shirk, major shirk.
Right?
These types of slaughtering,
this will make this animal what?
It has the ruling not only was this
shirk and not only is this
a possible invalidator of a person's
Islam, but also this is
making this animal into a mata. This
animal is now a
dead animal. It has the ruling of a
mata.
It's eating it is haram, its flesh is
haram, it is considered to be filthy.
Right?
Now, and so, the dead animal is
considered to be the eighth type of
najasa that is mentioned here in this
list.
[Silence]
Right? So, the
definition of a dead animal here, he
says, it is whatever has been
whatever dies in spite of itself without
being
slaughtered before it's official death.
A theca, so let's say there's a
shepherd, right? And this shepherd, one
of his sheep falls off the mountain,
hits the bottom, or a wolf takes one of
the sheep. And so, the shepherd runs
after it and runs the wolf off, and the
sheep is there. It's bleeding out, it's
dying, but the sheep is still alive.
It's going to die for sure. It's been
mortally wounded, but it's still
kicking, it's still moving.
So, the person takes his knife and he
slaughters it. This is called a theca.
So, he caught it. Person is driving down
the road, they hit a deer,
right? The deer is now mortally wounded.
It's going to die.
So, they grab a a knife and they say
bismillah and slaughter the deer at the
last moments before the deer is fully
dead and they butcher it at that moment.
This is called a vika.
This now has been caught. It's been
slaughtered properly by a Muslim or by a
Christian or by a Jew. Right? So, we
have the way that it is slaughtered and
then we have who is doing the
slaughtering. When these two come
together properly, the meat is halal.
When one of these two is missing, the
meat is haram.
Now. Masala subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
juddihi an yufaqqihana fi dinina wa an
yu'allimana min huma jahilna wa an
yubarika lana fil Qur'anil Azim wa an
yanfa'ana bima fihi minal
[Arabic recitation]